wie einsam es um russland wird konnte
man heute sehr symbolisch sehen als
nämlich der russische außenminister
lawrow auf eine rede in genf gehalten
hat am rande einer un menschenrechts
konferenz und schauen sie sich das an er
war zugeschaltet aus moskau und der saal
war so gut wie leer weil fast alle
diplomaten diesem saal verlassen hat ein
einsamer russischer außenminister den
kein mensch
zuhört ein starkes zeichen darüber von
gesprächen mit herbert bauernebel live
in new york herbert wie hast du wie
diesen moment wird das weiße haus diesen
moment werden die menschen in amerika so
einen moment wahrgenommen
ja das war wieder ein sehr symbolischer
moment natürlich wie isoliert russland
bereits ist er es auch in amerikanischen
medien an die spitze der schlagzeilen
geschafft hat wie gesagt es war ein
konzertierter protest aller delegierten
sie haben sofort mehr oder weniger
sofort den saal verlassen als er auch
mit seinem der außenminister mit seinem
geschwafel muss man eigentlich sagen
gegangen hat wonach die ukraine den
krieg begonnen hätte nachdem die ukraine
atomwaffen hätte mit der sie russland
bedrohen würde das wollte keiner mehr
hören alle sind hinaus man muss dazu
sagen nicht alle denn china und
nicaragua die delegierten sind sitzen
geblieben da sieht man auch welche
rollen freunde anführungszeichen jetzt
noch habt insgesamt ist dieses land so
isoliert wie nie wahrscheinlich in
seiner modernen geschichte und dieser
moment dieses symbolkraft ist auch hier
angekommen in den usa natürlich du bist
denn new york wo die vereinten nationen
aussetzen der zeit zu einer
ausserordentlichen un-vollversammlung
sich treffen aber vor allem schaut man
mit spannung auf die rede des
amerikanischen präsidenten joe biden das
ist nach unserer zeit mitten in der
nacht bei dir dann etwas später am tage
was wird von dieser rede erwartet
gebäuden der präsident hat eine große
chance mit diesem state oft irgendwann
reden das ist der traditionelle rede die
der amerikanische präsident jedes jahr
an die nation liefert um praktisch der
nation so die die lage zu erklären oder
wie es der nation geben laut seiner
einschätzung für joe biden wäre es eine
chance gewesen ist eine innenpolitische
agenda wieder ein bisschen flott zu
kriegen das wird jetzt natürlich alles
überschattet durch die ukraine krieg der
einen breiten raum dieser rede natürlich
ein nehmen wir joe biden muss hier
versuchen den amerikanern zu erklären
warum amerika nicht mehr getan hat um
den krieg überhaupt zu stoppen warum er
den weg gegangen ist russland ehrt
isolierenden versuchen und zu versucht
zu haben den westen zusammenzuhalten was
ihm teilweise gelungen ist aber joe
biden geht hier mit miserablen umfragen
werden umfragewerten ins rennen bei
dieser rede insgesamt sind noch mehr
laut der jüngsten umfrage 37 prozent der
amerikaner zufrieden mit seiner
amtsführung selbst aber der ukraine
krise sind es nur 39 prozent der
amerikaner die der politik des
präsidenten zustimmen und das ist ganz
ungewöhnlich denn normalerweise in
solchen welt krisen in kriegen wirklich
schlimmen zeiten schaden sich die
amerikaner doch meistens um ihren
präsidenten das hat man ja auch gesehen
nach den terroranschlägen des 11
september als george haben 90 prozent
zustimmung davon geräten ist das alles
ist bei joe biden nicht zu bemerken die
amerikaner halten ihn nach wie vor für
einen schwachen präsidenten und das ist
politische in ein großes problem